that's so crazy it's fun comes down old
school
right
old school
so this here is basically a rocket
rocket on my head just pummeling the
[ __ ] out of me this isn't a scene that
takes money as long as you have like the
creativity you have your scene this
change right here is brilliant
welcome back to another episode of
stuntmen react we are here with james
young who is an action designer and
stunt performer extraordinaire you might
know james from uh some of these obscure
little indie films avengers end game
captain america civil war this french
cult hit guardians of the galaxy james
i've been wanting you to be on this
couch for such a long time and i'm so
happy we're able to fit in your busy
schedule thanks man you know yeah you
know james marie tell us a little bit
about these films you've been working on
yeah i have been very fortunate to
actually design coordinate and second
you direct some of these fun movies i've
done about 10 movies wow yeah that's a
train
i imagine you have a lot of stories
well
let's just jump right in
this is probably one of the most fun
sets me you have been on and this is
probably one of the funniest scenes i've
seen you ever do so let's watch it and
then i want you to tell everybody the
story oh my god
you're doing it and how it felt
afterwards this thing here this is me on
the left and stephen on the right
so this here is basically a rocket
rocket on my head just pummeling the
[ __ ] out of me and i'm basically just
snapping my head backwards backwards
fours and then doing a face plant
the funny thing is you do this scene for
four five hours and then you gotta shoot
the rest of the scene oh man so the rest
of the scene if you continue it just
watch what i'm doing i'm asleep i'm
there as rocket's pedestal yeah
we share methods we share that's me
laying down like a pencil
so i had to sit there for two days
like that while they did michael rooker
and sean gunn who plays rocket sean was
sitting on my back for some of them like
that you actually see him in in action
so sean does all the kind of performance
capture and movement for rocket he'll
sit down in like a weird squat with his
legs crossed and be like he got you'll
be actually playing the character for
all of them so you just went from a
half a day of snapping your head
to crazy and then you got to sit like
this for two days on a cold sound stage
i've been through brick walls i've been
through windows i've been hit by cars
but my god that next day hurt i had
batman neck for months
right
very bad so there's something to be said
like honestly we often joke about
playing a dead body can get you injured
because you go about doing all this work
and then all of a sudden you've got to
stay cold and still it's a funny scene
to be a part of i i remember the pain
more than anything
[Music]
that was a fun day too that's just
inquiries ah so so funny rocket's my
favorite character from guardians 100
like
all about him it's great and i'll be
honest the guy into the galaxy as ghee
knows probably less work for a stunt
designer james knows exactly what he
wants james storyboards the whole movie
before he goes in so he's got a great
idea so when i go into design he shows
me what he's got and i'm just basically
just adding a small piece that's it it's
really just what james wants he knows
exactly what he wants so it's easy it's
fun it's such a great crew regardless
james is great people around him so
truly a joy to work with him
yeah it's it's these movies are just fun
man but again you go into that kind of
different aspect of action design this
is space green screen wires and kind of
more ability driven whereas you know
captain america you're slinging me
this is sort of the stranger yeah james
you were the one that put me on to this
anime yeah and this fight scene is to
this day one of my favorite fight scenes
i know it's one of your favorite fight
scenes yeah like if you guys want to see
a sword fight this is a sword fight the
word anime i mean we're all nerds here
we love all the animes but i think to a
lot of the general populaces animes or
the yeah all the funny like crazy
psychedelic stuff right it's not that
anymore the thing i like about this
anime it's not on that kind of
way you think anime is this fight you
could do this live action there's a lot
of cinematic shots in it and there's a
lot of great moments they even to me
there's western-style cinematography in
this you're going to see an empire that
strikes backshot you're going to see
some shots that are just phenomenal like
look at this
[Music]
here's your just bits of choreography
get the crowd going right now this shot
is empire strikes back ready
there's vader and luke
[Music]
now you're at the break the first break
of the fight you can go back and watch
that and you're about to see where that
happened and then one really good reveal
[Music]
and you can go back and actually see
those close little hits foreshadowing
right foreshadowing you get your break
the music's coming up you know you're
pumping everything this is where it's
like the standoff that was act one now
you're knack too
most fights should have three acts yes
right
it's a story this piece right here my
favorite part of the fight
breathed out yeah i know straight the
cup bam yeah
comes down old school
right old school
dude like the strategic frames you get
one frame of the look right but it's set
up in a way where like your mind's
memory the short-term memory of visual
that you have like holds that frame in
your mind a little bit longer i think
what anime does is it subconsciously
programs you in some of those things
because it's art you don't you only have
24 frames i mean when i worked in
animation the rules that you hey james
you worked in animation i did i used to
work in animation i did storyboard
animatics i've i started on jackie chan
adventures batman beyond wait really
yeah
cool yeah dragon tails cliffy the big
red dog wow
i mean the fight scenes in clifford are
pretty great i know right
but that's the fight i highly recommend
anyone to check this whole movie out
it's just beautifully done if you want
one of the best animated fights of the
last 45 years arcane eco versus jinx
you look at this fight right here the
dark colors this is what i love it's not
about the fight it's about what you're
painting they haven't seen each other
since kids they used to fight his kids
to train everything about this fight i'm
getting goosebumps right now it's just
perfection to me
this change right here
is brilliant because you're going back
in time everything's about time in this
fight and i love that the clock is a big
thing this is where innocence kicks in
so now you're programming your audience
something different you've come in dark
but now you're showing them this and
you're enjoying it so good and i love
the way they did it kind of stop motion
just to signify time the biggest thing i
think for a lot of fight scenes is it's
like this what's your artistic aesthetic
what are you trying to tell the story in
a different way the hardest thing to do
as an action designer is take every
scene and think about what is that
little extra piece well you know if
we're doing a flashback scene what are
you doing it goes into that echo fight a
cool graphic narrative that is going to
drive it as well graphic edit they're
all the tool to push people to
subconsciously get what you want but the
real kick of this fight comes when you
come back to reality right
[Music]
beautiful beautiful twist
and then just absolutely bludgeons are
and i was watching this like oh my god
oh my god like what the [ __ ]
it comes from innocence per beauty to
absolute i will kill you one of the
important things for fights is to take
the audience on an emotional ride the
ability to make the audience expect
something and then rip the expectation
away from them is it just pulls them so
much further into your story it's it's a
great technique from a story
construction scene that's so hard to do
because you obviously need to get people
attached to those characters you're only
going to expect the character to win if
it's like a main character of course
yeah but you also need to build your
story so you can then kill your main
character and not just break your entire
story not your main character but one of
the main characters yeah again action
design in a different aspect but you're
telling the same story you're subverting
expectations you're building a character
it's there's an aesthetic to it so to me
you're emotionally
investing people this will be the
greatest war the world has ever seen we
need the greatest warrior
ah here we go okay so james this is like
one of the things that you definitely
use to teach people yeah so what i want
and i think the audience wants is for
you to walk us through this amazing
fight and break it down how you would
break it down yeah
that's a great shot
[Music]
and you know how hard it is to fight
with full spears
this is some of the hardest work you can
do like the shield heavy shield the
timing the spirit there's a lot that
goes into this end all be always weapons
hardest thing to do because
to teach an actor to throw hands you see
everyone knows their hands right but to
put a weapon in someone's hand and you
often hear you've got to have the weapon
an extension of yourself that's true in
order to actually do well with the
weapon it needs to be a part of you not
to mention making it look like it's
snappy and fast when right spears are
not snappy and fast i mean any weapon
you know like any weapon you're using
the hardest thing to sell on camera's
intent it's like if i'm throwing a hook
punch over your head i've got to
accelerate it to show the intent i want
to take your head off it's a little bit
more dangerous with the weapon right so
it's a little bit more involved in it
you're constantly getting problem
solving in every single move too you are
he's going to stab here i don't regard
psych if i twist this way i do if i put
my shield here and i do a cool viper
strike with my sword yeah
it makes sense for my character so then
what are you going to look at as well is
look at the way they're moving one thing
you've got to lock onto is like what
they're going into right hector's you
know he made a mistake by killing the
cousin you can see his heart is almost
conflicted in this fight achilles is
angry and he's also been built up the
whole movie is to be in this incredible
fighter so as the audience we know right
hector just knows the myth of achilles
right the way this fight is performed
hector is a little bit more wild a
little bit more defensive brad is doing
a carter he's literally
he's very rudimentary and very set in
his movement panning well that tells me
it's a better warrior it's someone that
literally moving per beat knows
everything he's doing it like he's done
it before hector all wild yeah achilles
is in the pocket he's toying with him
there's a moment where he slaps the
blade away and it's so disrespectful
it's so small it just it says a lot to
me his this is not a fight he's picking
him the pieces he's making up there it
is yeah get the [ __ ] out of here right
this is basically breaking morale of a
city
and that's why i love this fight again
all these emotions of the anger the
uncertainty the prior idea of who you're
fighting is everything in this fight
[Music]
the kill savor the kill he literally
just bludgeoned him down in front of the
whole family he broke him around the
city and then the best and that part of
this fight he just drags the body away
that wasn't a fight between two men this
was literally like your movies that's
the movie that's right movie right there
you know also talking about like the
accessibility of filmmaking this isn't a
scene that takes money as long as you
have like the creativity you have your
scene it's two dudes in a dirt spot yeah
that's it that's it that's all you need
i mean yeah there's a cast in the
background but you don't need the castle
nope you just be two dudes in a field
yeah the biggest thing is the crowd and
the dudes that's it you don't need any
sorry yeah well the story's just a story
it's the biggest thing yeah yeah yeah
grab a pencil and a piece of paper you
got your story yeah all right guys fun
fact james is actually a lord in england
something like that
and
i am either gonna become a lord a baron
or duke north or duchess
you get to pick
comment below and based on how many
subscriptions we get off of this video i
have to become that and that'll be my
title on this show of stunt memory it's
binding james promise james promise he
would use his power as his lordship
to bestow upon ye
his rightful lands
[Laughter]
so yeah subscribe
hanging out with freddie and matt when
we're shooting our punch for punch
episode and i'm always happy when i can
show a clip to someone that might like
it and they haven't seen it or heard of
heard of it before so freddie thanks for
the recommendation i'm now using it on
the show to like flex as if i have like
really great tastes and action scenes
let's watch it i want to hear what you
guys think
such a japanese moment here yep
that's so crazy it's fun
it's a good comp shot yeah yeah oh nice
[Music]
that's a charlie chaplin shot there
oh
i love the double grab yeah unexpected
oh nice that's cool sick oh that sucks
oh gosh that was two wire gags that
sucks oh
that's fun
yeah that's real fun i just see the
logistics of that that's bananas
you can follow the action very clearly
nice very well done do you know what
helps you though it's not an actor
yeah you got the mask on that's true
that's why shang chi was so good because
simile put a lot of the working all you
want as an action designer is your actor
to give you as much as possible because
at the end of the day i don't want to
craft a fight based on what my actor
can't do and cut cut cut
you know you want you want to have the
freedom you want to get freedom
[Music]
douglas fairbanks that's nice oh things
aren't looking good he's in trouble
how's it gonna get out of this one ah
the
nice
grenade
sick
nice that's good special effects there
with that right that is really well
built yeah seeing the camera on it as it
falls over yeah just the gravity shifts
like you can't fake gravity shifting
that's sick
the effects that's dope
that is sick that's cool that's really
cool you're still in the motion so well
there's well done man
all right that's it that's really cool
man so this little sequence where he's
falling down between like the stairwell
inside the building it looks so intense
i imagine that's a lot of scraped elbows
right it is we did something similar on
civil war we had uh kofi who was
doubling chadwick at the time when they
were fighting in the college he got
thrown into something like that we just
dropped him straight down it's just a
straight gap that's really cool you can
using that space is something different
i think with action scenes we're always
trying to do something different so
environment can always help but this is
really well done it's really well done i
really like that whole sequence yeah
like they're putting themselves into
tough physical spaces and it's hard to
film spaces like that's the thing
there's like fights in bathrooms there's
fights on the floor they're between like
a stairwell on the side of a building
it's like are you gonna squeeze a camera
in there yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but
it won't get a good angle right it's
also the size of your camera as well you
know for a lot of stuff we shoot on
you're looking at sony venice's alexa
mini's it's insane so they obviously
bungee the camera that's just some great
rigging that really is just a good spot
to do a fight some great rigging you can
definitely tell they had a good reading
team because not only do they do the
same but then they do the scaffolding
scene which is just both of them are
like flexes you know oh yeah that's
bananas a lot of great action is a good
dance between your stunt team your vfx
team and your special effects team yeah
it's usually all in one you're trying to
come together and do this you know to
wrap things up do you have like just an
old fight scene that you've done that's
on youtube oh
yeah
so what this was is after i finished
winter soldier i had that really bad
injury i wasn't allowed to work for six
months i was just training trying to get
better and i finally got back to
a place where i could actually stop
throwing hands again so we just went
down to malibu for a day so it's just a
good practice fight
and it's always hard to do with knives
and we're trying to like did a little
bit of hunted style just trying to make
it a little bit kind of realistic but
playing around with it at the same time
that's not realistic at all
[Laughter]
yeah but this is you know done on the
fly this is like coming up with the
choreo manny shooting it and directing
us and just getting us back into it so
this is always really fun but this is to
us this is training this is not this is
this is us how you would train as a
stunt man go to the gym practice the
heavy bad practice your techniques but
the real worth is getting together with
people and shooting the fight and
criticizing yourself so everybody out
there who thinks making movies is
inaccessible here is a youtube video
with freaking gee and james in the woods
in their like jeans
a lot of the times i give homework to
people say look you want to know how
jackie fights go take a jackie fight and
recreate shot for shot yeah like that's
literally it that's one of the best ways
you can practice anything like that's
what you're doing for like visual
effects like if you pull up the matrix
lobby scene samurai made the matrix
lobby scene shot per shot when we were
in like junior high school oh yeah it
looks really janky my run up the wall is
me on a green screen just being rotated
oh i love it
but that's that's amazing like you know
you're problem solving yeah you're
learning he's like okay this shot's
needed for this beat the shots needed
for this speed okay this is a setup here
that's different from this and you
really learn how to make it like if you
can't make a fight scene shot for shot
you're not gonna be able to make your
own a cinema level fight scene on your
own without you know having a template
just shooting the thousands and
thousands of previews that i've shot is
you learn you know working with the vfx
team i know like you know where angles
are going to go better you just you
learn just you got to do it one of my
favorite quotes is from james cameron
you got a phone look i'm a director
everything else is your rate that's it
that's it but this is what you can do to
help you like go take a fight scene
recreate it shop for shot you'll
understand the why they did it like this
what sells what doesn't sell and then
also what you'll learn what's more
important is when you can put an actor
in when you can't because that's us
doing it but there's definitely four or
five of these shots i wouldn't put an
actor in you know like it's a lot of
puzzle pieces that you're really coming
together but the first step is picking
up the camera yeah i mean when we're
hiring a corridor hey pro tip if we do
our next hiring round at some point when
we look at people's reels it's not just
the work that they've done we also look
to see what work did they do for fun
yeah because if somebody doesn't have
any work in their real that they've just
done on their own like how much do you
truly love it right if you're not doing
it when there's no money involved and
like you're not doing work that's not
going in your real when there's no money
involved like
is the passion really there exactly
that's true
man
as you can see by watching this whole
episode james is super cool he does a
bunch of awesome work you can see more
of it on his instagram ju10 there's a
link in the description below it's on
the screen go check it out if you want
to see more of these clips all right
james
i want to get you back on the couch but
i know i'm not going to see you for
another four years
it won't be like that it won't be like
that i'll be i'll be happy to come back
you guys been great so thank you so much
that's it we'll see you guys in the next
one thank you so much for joining us